this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon everybody welcome once
again to the sunset Safari here in Duma
in the sabi sands South Africa where it
is a very nice 29 degrees Celsius 86
degrees Fahrenheit and well we always
have the Juke of Juma who has been lying
up around treehouse dam for the whole
day and just before we went laughs he's
decided to get up and start moving
how splendid is that but what is
interesting about it is he started
scent-marking and the line that he's on
right now is he is pretty much a few
meters to the right of the line that
huka Murray came down last week straight
down here to treehouse dam hukum or he
came down this path it but went on the
that side of it went straight across
down to the I in a dead and certain
Ghana has waited for the sunshine he's
waited for to dry up and now he is doing
his territorial duties in the middle of
the day which is just it boggles the
mind sometimes it's probably to do with
the fact that it is so windy you can see
the vegetation is blowing as we go and
he's probably been waiting for a long
time to do this but he's been quite
hungry because we've got a TV show this
evening actually had hardly come out and
spent many hours with ten Ghana him a BK
came out at a bit of a bro session
Archie which is quite a stand it's in
Ghana tempted to female kudos large
kudos but he missed so he's definitely
hungry and he's also sent marking as he
goes but I think he needs a meal in him
his belly is looking very very empty and
he got a little bit of a I'm not sure if
it was a wound on the head we didn't see
anything earlier those of you who are
with me this morning we didn't notice
anything on his head but it was a bit of
blood on the head just not possibly from
a tick that he might have scratched
we're gonna get a little bit closer in
and see if we can see that and see if it
is a wound in fact off it is just a tick
that he managed to
grachov and it's his own blood burst on
to the surface attempt when the wind is
like this that cools things down and it
makes these stealth movements of
leopards even more proficient okay well
we're gonna be spending the afternoon
with Tenggara because he is just a Juke
and a wonderful character we love him so
don't forget you can get in touch with
us on hashtag Safari live on the YouTube
chat stream but in the meantime let's go
all the way up to the Maasai Mara to say
good afternoon to Isaac welcome to Masai
Mara everyone from windy situation in
Kruger to more windy areas in the Mara I
have tapas here with me welcome this
afternoon everybody to this afternoon's
game Drive my name is Isaac and on
camera G Andre
welcome to the Masai Mara it's a bit
windy but all in all we are happy that
you can join us this afternoon on this
afternoon's game Drive it is such a
beautiful scene I have here I have lots
and lots of topi it's not always that I
come across this big head of tapa like
this everywhere this time of the year
and the main reason is that they are
migratory animals they do go to the
Serengeti for the annual migration and
then come back but we do have you know
small resident hearts that stick around
and as you can see lots of young ones a
lot of those these young ones we are
born in October from October they start
giving birth and behind there I have
Impala also it's very windy as you can
tell you know
crafts is moving very fast and also I
think you might hear it from my
microphone the top e is an antelope only
found in East African plains and they
amount to around twenty to thirty
thousand during the migration in case
you're not aware of what I'm talking
about the great migration is an annual
movement of animals from southern
Serengeti in Tanzania to Kenya it
involves the wildebeest zebra topi
Eiland nomadic cuts that move in one
direction moving for about five hundred
kilometers one way at the moment
majority of them are way down in the
Serengeti a place called Navi that's
where they go give birth so that is what
is called the great migration and this
and this animal usually migrates you
know from my active topi with me here
let me test send you to Trish who's got
our sleeping lion
good afternoon everybody is so glad to
have you on board as usual mashaallah
here from Juma in South Africa as always
and I've caught up with my lovely Avoca
male yet again now there is a second
male hanging around his just in the
bushes off to the right but we don't
actually have a visual of him with the
camera but I can see him with my eyes
just off to the right behind these
bushes you won't be able to see it at
the moment but I'm gonna reposition
maybe a little later and be able to show
you hopefully now we are in the middle
of the road and there is a car behind us
so well you know what it's not as if he
the car can do anything if the lines in
the middle of the road so okay good
they've decided to take another route so
he's kind of capitalized on all the
shade here on the road while we BK and
IB K's on camera with me while we have
to suffer in the Sun but he has found
all the shade and has decided that he's
gonna take it all haven't you well you
deserve it we know that you're not
yourself you're a little bit injured so
there you go you can have the shade for
now rain covers are off and the Sun is
out so hopefully we can get some really
nice shots and have some really nice
sightings I'm sure we will now he hasn't
moved far at all he where he was in the
morning was not even a hundred meters
from here less than that by far now if
he would let me get past then I could
show you the other male in the bushes
but this is quite exciting to have them
both around I think that kind of maybe
settles what we were tell what we were
thinking about the reasons he could be
injured
so if the other male is around maybe he
he is not had a fight with him anyway I
am going to try and reposition so he can
get a view of the other male in the
meantime let's go to David in the Mara
very well done Trish to have sported a
lion and we got one grumpy animal here
and not sure why I would say he is
grumpy but hopefully he gonna settle
down and try and behave and one of you
jumbo jumbo my name is David as usual
and his main camera is Archie Archie how
are you sir very good I think today
might be one of those weekend's that you
call the weekend of the big five because
I think I heard Steve talking about in
Ghana maybe he must have seen lived and
now Trish with a lion and myself now
with the Buffalo so you got three or the
big five
so can we have some work today are all
presenters going to request them we work
on the big five because this Buffalo
here is one of the big five and as Trish
correctly said is one of the most grumpy
animals now it's very windy here where
we are you can see how the grass is
moving and it shows you how windy it is
and that's why this grumpy animals here
don't look very comfortable
can you see the grass there we think oh
I think we might be getting rains maybe
tonight or tomorrow this is how it
starts at the signs of rain and I
believe Isaac Trish and Steve already
told you keep talking to us any comments
just sent us ask me why do I think that
grass is moving left and right is that
grass or which any questions please do
send them hashtag surfer live on Twitter
so we got some one rock one good work to
do and got their buffaloes and yeah
Trish with Ally on Steve with leopard
now let's work on a big fight before
long and let's go back I guess
tooting
or with its two oval welcome back ting
gana is on the top of the termite mound
and I do apologize I got so carried away
with the fact that we have a moving
leopard in the afternoon and I forgot to
introduce myself and mr. Sebastian Aram
beyond their camera though I'm Steve of
course and that's ting Ghana and he is
definitely on the move is now on top of
the termite mound having a look see if
anything is moving in the long grass
apart from all the trees and the grasses
everything is swaying and with his very
keen vision he's trying to see if
there's anything just stumbling around
that he can maybe try and move towards
it's such a characteristic thing that we
see I'm sorry he's suddenly hidden from
view can I go back and meet his hip oh
there we go he knows there he is
so can you see right on the top of his
head there's a bit of a blood stay in
there I think it's just from a tick cuz
it's not seeping or anything it's just a
little bit of blood I think it was from
a tick that got squashed there's another
one on the top left of his head
another big tick up there when they get
nice and gorged and full of blood before
generally falling off to breed and the
longer ask - then give us enormous
amounts of itching when we walk around
but he caught that one probably with his
claw and scratched it off and that would
have led to a little bit of a blood
stain well he's just coming down the
term up mount there he is hello Tinky
ear all saying hello Tinky well mr.
deeds it's wonderful to be with him I
told you all he'd be back and well what
a good opportunity for him to be back as
well to say goodbye to our season 1 of s
ABC 3 that is on this evening
sorry Sam I'm taking you through a
little bit of a day that's yeah
morroco he is a gorgeous boy he's a he's
getting a little bit old you can see
that in his face his face in his fur
he's getting a little bit droopy skin
and maybe do it a little bit of Botox or
something I don't I don't advocate any
of that can you imagine a leopard with
Botox the image is just too much Dingaan
is not that vain he doesn't mind he
knows he's getting on a bit he's still a
very powerful leopard a very loud and
confident leopard and he is walking
directly east so he's coming back to the
road called weavers nest and he is
finding every conceivable bush he
confined to that demarcates his
territory and interesting to see where
he's going to lead us what is on his
mind but it's not only myself and
Shoshanna and Isaac and David art this
afternoon we've also got Sydney he's on
a vehicle and he would like to say good
afternoon
so sorry about that guys but I have
found something great for us I found
another Avoca male so I did tell you
that he was in the bushes there and we
managed to spot him now he is it's quite
a thick block and I think if I get in
there I'll be able to close to him so
I'm being a bit sensitive and I'm
staying out cha on the road now he's not
too far from his brother so like I was
saying before there's the brother
dearest sitting in the shade hugging at
all as I was saying before I hope this
kind of puts to sleep the suspicions
that we thought he may be in a coalition
internal kind of fight because they are
still around each other they were
sitting with each other as we drove up
and then the one sat down on the road
and the other walked across the road not
too far at all so to me it seems that
they're still still quite a coalition
and they don't have any sort of internal
squabbles yet at least
so what created the hole in his head is
still a question to be answered yes
we're talking about you
like I said it's become quite hot now in
June 29 and 84 degrees Fahrenheit so
everyone's looking for a bit of shade
and I am too so while I look for some
shade let's go over to Sydney who has
some zebra what a beautiful sighting
I've got lovely a zebra standing right
in the middle of the impala head these
two different species are feeding
together this afternoon and most of all
good afternoon and welcome on board this
is Sydney formerly me cozy and I'm
travelling with Shenzhen Kesey who is my
camera operator this afternoon we are
going to definitely look for the
interesting game for you this afternoon
you can talk to us by following us on
Twitter hashtag Safari Live
you can also follow us on YouTube chat
stream so the weather this afternoon
rain is still promising don't get
surprised I'm still having the roof and
you might get disturbed with the poles
we're viewing these animals so impalas
and the zebras when they are fitting
together like this they do help each
other
a lot when it comes to the
identification of the predators so if
you can check animals such as the zebras
they are very much popular of connecting
with animals such as well beasts because
well the Beast has got a poor eyesight
but here I know both impalas as well as
the zebras they both got good eyesight
so it means any animal any big data
which might try to go this even it could
where I can see the kudu running away
there so it means it's not just the
zebras here so these three different
species is the Kouros and zebras and
impalas when animals are feeding like
this this is what is called safety in
numbers because it's very much difficult
for a predator to single one animal out
when
they are in a very big head like these
and see some of these impalas are now
feeding under the trees day so now we
are going to leave this beautiful
bachelor head of impalas and cross over
to the Masai Mara where David is having
something well I was talking about the
big five and I could be wrong here but I
think now we can close that chapter of
talking about the big five because after
the buffalos I just took one loop and
came to these heart of elephants here
which complete the list of the big five
I'm sure most of you know what I'm
talking about but just in case we go to
animals let's call the big five in
Africa which are elephants Buffalo's
lions leopards and rhinos they apologies
we still have one more to get to make
that list complete of the big five now
the wind continues hauling here still
blowing and you can see through the
grass and this is the red porch grass
it's just being moved
and should we get any rains now we would
say we should get easterly rains coming
this way in this direction but I do not
think the time now it could be maybe
tomorrow the day after but when this has
come this elephants will still be here
but this when this you know rains come
nothing much gonna change now we've got
two seasons of rainfall in Kenya the
long rains and the short rains so what
we could be gone into the wrong lanes
and it could be at a time you know how
much but again the weather has been very
erratic as last couple of years so it
could come early or it could even come a
rather late African elephants who call
them small hearts of anything five
sometimes up to a hundred of course when
you get a hundred that we definitely
different families coming together so if
you look at that grass carefully where
they're eating you notice is a lot
greener than the other grass around in
that area and of course much shorter
definitely more nutritious and secondly
our guess it has more moisture content
in it always very much vehicle led by
one female a Marchak and she'll always
decide where to graze where to browse
where to go have a drink or time to go
have a drink
she's like a commander
this is very exit now we have walked
four of the big five now let's see
whether we can get in the rain at one
point and then those who move on as just
hauling and hauling my my ears because
of the wind and let's go back to the
Duke of jummah I think with Steve
Orville really see is a bit of his
profile and very easy to see how thick
that neck is the julep well he was
walking through and two steam box
probably about thirty meters away
decided they were going to take a bolt
and they both went in different
directions and if quarters attention for
a moment in stood up on a big log to see
if we could find one but that's the
strategy with small antelope like that
they will run a short distance very
quickly and stand dead still and well
I've just seen it and it's worked for
them a couple that is probably going to
survive the day but he's still trying to
find one one went off in the direction
is now looking the other one went off in
the direction behind us he tried to see
where that one went but I think it
concealed itself quite nicely
Roslin's you wonder how big a dewlap can
get and well there we go that's like
probably the best example mean Singhal
is an enormous Leopard and I think
that's as good an example of a fully
matured jewel app that I've ever seen
and not many other leopards that I've
seen or as big as sin Ghana but they all
have a similar sort of size but I've
never seen anything bigger than what you
see there with the Juke so a very very
good example right there Roslyn
now he's headed straight there's a
couple of pans along the way here but he
is definitely hungry because he didn't
drink it tree house watching home while
we were there he just kind of walked
along after being in the shade maybe he
enjoyed the tick off of his head
Charlotte universe leopards would most
certainly hunter topi don't know if
they'd manage an adult topi and I'm but
certainly the youngsters but yeah the
the idea behind the topi is that they
are Plains game and their strategy is to
be able to stand and they're very
vigilant animals the ability to stand up
tall and to look and be attentive the
Valda beast often don't even notice
predators approaching the top he is very
very on top of things and I think a
leopard would have a hard trance trying
to sneak up on a topi in their short
grass habitats but a young topi most
certainly is a risk of a leopard but I
think with the vigilance of the adults
they probably be able to evade them but
leopards will hunt absolutely anything
they can possibly get their claws or
teeth into I mean David and Ralph both
had leopards in the Mara last year with
small giraffe of the tree so now that is
something that you just wouldn't think
would be possible for a leopard but they
are opportunistic and if they can catch
it and bring it down they most certainly
will for example he'll go for a bird
you'll go for a snake you'll go for
anything that is catchable even
tortoises from time to top you're gonna
walk up to the waters up there the water
is grace this is so muddy you're gonna
have a drink boy yes he is there we go
look at the size of his feet now
honestly wish I could just give him some
of my water because because of the
erosion from the rainfall that's filled
that little pan with a fair amount of
sediment a fair amount of runoff and mud
prefer this to tree house watching all
the teams and then you can see how long
in the whiskers are I was asked a
question this morning is why are lipids
whiskers longer than lions and I wonder
if anyone out they can answer for me are
they in fact longer than lions or do
they just stand out a bit more on the
lipids face because of the colors and
the spots it's not something I've really
paid attention to in the past but now
looking up close at the large head and
face often gana you can see
how enormously long his whiskers are as
he drinks up the entire pan really
you're very blessed to be able to spend
time with these animals close proximity
okay well let's quickly go up to the
masai mara where gigi has moved off from
large Buffalo to baby buffaloes running
lovely any time you'd see a cat drinking
I think a Steve you feel very lucky to
see the you know Duke of Juma doing that
but I got some more balloons from the
two three that I saw earlier now I got
to be a group that you call a heart of
Buffalo here that is getting very
confused by the wind
most of the herbivores when it gets very
windy it brings a bit of anxiety in them
in the sense that they know the cuts
will always be trying to go get all of
them and the hearing is not very
accurate they smell also the smell don't
smell very very good so they're always a
bit careful when it's windy like this
but now I stopped here is because there
were two small ooh calves oh wow that
Buffalo has a short tail and you see
that small baby there and see how clever
they are they'll always put the young
ones in the midst of the group and I
think that's the mother who is walking
very close to the calf so the wind
brings lots of confusion to these
animals because all their senses do not
work a quickly and they have known out
of experience animals or predators like
lions will always be taking that
advantage to get them not sure they can
hear the wind blowing from where we are
me and Archie
Archie's my camera operator these
afternoon and all those small little
birds you're seeing flying on top of
those buffalos are called the Ox because
Linda how are you today and you say they
are so very cute and Linda especially to
see them with a wind blowing there makes
them I guess even cuter not sure that
an English word but I think that makes
them even more cuter to see the wind
blowing and see the size of that small
little baby there I think you Archie but
the mother is very very cautious because
even a thing you see how they keep
telling their heads they would not know
what direction any danger would come
from you see how they smell you see that
I'm putting her nose up it's just to
pick up in a smell because they know now
the hearing senses I would say almost
not not to count on they better counter
on smell of course if the wind is Ryan I
got a question here from Ryan why that
Buffalo is something and the same wind
is blowing to my ears and me me start
Christian so what she's trying to do is
to smell see what that you know she can
pick any spell of lions or anything
there Ryan very good question and you'd
like to know where the Buffaloes are
native to Africa yes Ryan buffaloes are
native to Africa and exactly that's why
we call them the African Buffalo's have
been found here and I think when some of
the Europeans came way back at the
beginning of the century to South Africa
and I think is an area code kept not
sure how far it is from Cape Town
because we call this buffalos their
African Cape Buffalo's yes the native
here and we will compare them to the
Bisons also to the water buffalo which
you get maybe in Asia and North America
well I need to move this particular area
is an area I call this sausage Republic
and so Stadium took your butt about a
particular pride of violence want to
give you one more quick look of that
both those buffaloes because I am
enjoying how the wind is bringing them
some worries and I want to move some
some Lions here in this particular area
see the small you know cuff is just
following the mother very quick closely
not to make any mistakes while talking
of Buffalo Calf small babies of Buffalo
I think Isaac got a small babies of a
type of burger
yes I'm talking about wind it is also
very windy here and I think it's an
advantage to certain animal and others
are a very big disadvantage over here I
have female ostrich with her five chicks
this is an ostrich that we know before
from quite a while she had about ten
chicks she has lost five and the five
she's hard she's her hold on to she's
been holding on to them for the last
about three months and they are doing
quite fine so we're very very happy
we're hoping to see never reach maturity
this is the master ostrich and there is
a female it's quite an unusual setting
because usually you come across a pair
and the chicks they take care of the
chicks I don't know what happened to the
male we haven't seen him since December
maybe he decided to abandon the family
which is the rather sad because they
usually try and bring up the chicks
together until they almost quite big
squat you know much one and they leave
but we don't know exactly what happened
to the male looks like she's quite as
soon level you know clever mother
because she is moving downwind so in
case of any threat she can see it and
nothing would attack her I remember to
join me in conversation on hashtag
Safari life or you can you know watch us
on YouTube livestream can ask us as many
questions as possible
is it I don't I didn't get your name but
you did ask you know how many eggs two
ostriches lay they say a female ostrich
will lay up to four eggs in a day aren't
yes that's if I got your name right yeah
they do lay about you know four and what
happens is that when a female is ready
after mating to lay some eggs she will
lay the eggs she'll find a spot on the
ground and then she'll lay an egg the
fill the rest of the females that have
been meeting with the same L will follow
suit and lay eggs in the same spot so in
a nest you can find up to sixty eggs 66
0 but of those 60 maybe 40 will hatch
after incubation of about three months
and then of those forty maybe fifteen
reach maturity infant mortality is very
high because of extreme sunlight too
much water fast
you know jackals leopards lions will
also go for the chicks so the mortality
rate is very high at a very young age
but yes if I hope I answered your
question right they look like if they
are very happy with these guys
Jemma you asked me how long do chicks
stay with their moms
they will stay sometimes even forever
they were staying forever
sometimes but when they are big enough
like mature to start meeting if the
flock is too big they might break away
so they will stay even up to two three
years before the flop getting too bigger
than break away but I have seen where
they stick with their moms you know for
forever they become part of the big big
family this is a beautiful setting and
this is coming to you from the Masai
Mara and these guys were once you know
under serious threat a few years back
when there was a lot of
butterfly girl asked me you know if we
know how many ostriches are found in the
Mara of course we don't know these are
you know birds or you know animals that
they had you know to keep track off so I
don't know I would lie to you it's an
animal we don't keep track so I don't
know how many but we do have a very
healthy population as you can see we
have chicks right now this is not the
case that you know and about 10 years
ago where you didn't see them because
everybody was having on opening ostrich
farms and so people came and stole eggs
but there has been restrictions and who
can have ostrich farms and so we have
seen a very healthy population of
ostriches coming back so don't you worry
I don't know the number but we do have a
very good population of the Messiah
ostrich I'll proceed on and see what
else I can find for you because they
have gone over the horizon and all I can
share with you now isn't this beautiful
Plains over here quite a huge expanse
where I am very open and this is typical
of Mara
besides it's very very very very open
you can
okay while I continue see what I can
find for you let me send you to greater
Kruger where Trish has got a lion for
you guys
Wow just look at the way that Mane is
blowing in the wind hey my gorgeous boy
absolutely stunning now the most
heartwarming thing happened they were he
was sitting on the road the one with the
injured the injury on his skull and then
the brother came out from the bushes and
nozzles him a few times
picked him up and then saw that well not
picked him up physically but sort of
like helped him and they lodged each
other and then it almost like he said
come bro let's go have a drink and
they've just stopped over somewhere you
can see his mouth still wet and his
brothers sort of walked off to the right
there oh look at that is that not the
most beautiful thing
hey guy get a good look at his teeth now
absolute poser
she's got my my nose out guys so I'm
just having a closer look
Wow he's been struggling to keep up with
his brother quite a bit and his brothers
been moving in a really slow slow slow
pace to kind of just I suppose help him
and guide him but it was just the most
heartwarming thing he'd stop every now
and then to make sure that this lumpy
one would catch up that's just been the
sweetest thing ever
now he's just flopped down in another
patch of shade and his brothers moved
off but I bet I could put money on the
fact that their brothers not far off at
all because he has been staying with him
the whole time and trying to help him
Jonathan would like to know if he could
actually be pushed out of the coalition
if his injuries get worse um I'm
actually not sure what I can tell you is
in my suspicions I don't think that will
happen I don't think so but you know
ready who knows he could the injuries
could become so bad that he actually
gets left behind in which case the other
two brothers just sort of move ahead and
don't come back as opposed to being
physically pushed out because of his
injuries but being left behind that
could that could definitely happen I
think but at the moment seeing this
interaction with the two of them I don't
think that's gonna happen anytime soon
because he's so concerned about his
limping brother here either I really
don't think it's come to that yet
I want to just angle myself a bit better
all the viewers say he looks so lazy
well that's a lazy lion for you that's
what they do in the day laze around look
for a bit of shade you know get the wind
blowing through their Mane he's been
resting a lot though even this morning
when I saw him he had not moved very
much from that from how I had seen him
the day before which is not a great sign
because usually what he should be doing
is sort of patrolling his area his
territory and scent-marking
especially after the rain when most of
it would have been washed away he would
go and resend mark all those areas and I
haven't seen him doing it maybe he's
just relying on his brothers for now
okay
his brother is actually next to him on
the other side I am going to reposition
a bit and then yeah I'm gonna because I
can see him just kind of at the edge
there so I'm going to reposition not
gonna get too close but I want to just
angle so we can see the brother as well
hello boy you're lifting your head up
there we go BK can you see him
yeah Dixon says bonds mean a lot to
lions they certainly do they are the
only cat that lives in such a type of
social structure and with so much social
bonding going on so it is important and
that is kind of telling from their
success they're the apex predators and
that's because very well one of the
reasons is because of their social bonds
and the way they reaffirm these bonds
and they kind of you know each member of
the pride is valuable in some way
but I just love how he's waiting with
their brother and they and I'm saying
they're waiting because it's as if
they're taking pit stops along the way
just so that Limpy can sort of
recuperate
david says they look like they're on a
yoga diet I don't even know what a yoga
diet is is that just healthy healthy
veggies that's not gonna do much for you
is it
Oh yogurt yogurt diet even that's a bit
far-fetched for them but I think yoga
diet was even worse I think the one with
the injury could do with some yoga he's
look so stiff when he gets up and he
starts to move around and that back leg
is looking really really swollen not
great signs but he's got his brother
around to help him
and you can see that he's super tired
and he's just flopped down there but the
brothers still got his head up because I
have a feeling they know exactly where
they need to go or want to go because
they missioned they were really really
walking fast they were not sort of
wandering about looking for a nice spot
of shade not at all
well these brothers are on a mission and
apparently so is Isaac so let's go to
him
welcome back I'm driving aimlessly here
looking for something
I haven't found but even without
anything it is a lovely view that I have
in front of me I cannot complain I know
there will be something maybe up here
and I can see lots and lots of game you
know long ways there's a big herd of
buffalo over there maybe 300 there's a
big heart of eland across the other side
about maybe 30 so I'm not complaining
I'll see something soon
the area I am in is called ly plains in
our map of Maasai Mara
we have different names for different
areas and this area is called ly ly is a
certain type of tree in Maasai it's
medicinal and it's what quickly forms
that sometimes they cut it and used to
build the corral
so that they can protect animals at
night I think it used to occur here I
don't see very many at the moment but
you know that's the name of this area if
you have a map of the Maasai Mara just
look out for that name and it will tell
you exactly where I am
sometimes it's always nice to stop and
you know have a look because sometimes
you will miss something when you are
just driving around
so I'll just scan around while J and Ray
also uses our you know camera to see if
there is anything but you know scanning
all around it is just a beautiful scene
everywhere in front here it's just miles
and miles of beautiful endless plains
okay while we're scanning and those
actually are buffalos you see that over
there
those are ball follows and while I Drive
to get close to them let me send you
over to David
I hope he's getting lucky in looking for
the sausages
once I jump out of the cab for a change
because when I was in Juma last year I
kept talking about the marula trees
which were huge trees but then I would
like to show you one of the iconic tree
off the Mara and this is a fig tree and
I first won't show you how large these
trees are and if I do my both hands like
that I'm not even half with a tree and
you can see I need about myself and
Archie and Isaac and Steve and Tricia
for us to just go around that trees now
looking up on this tree they make a very
good shared a very solid trees and they
tend to remain green all around the
silver windy if you look at the grass
here as r2 showing you how win it is but
the reason mainly also I came down here
it's because there's a branch that was
brought down and I guess it's by the
elephant's that I will not pick it up
because ideally we do not do this it's
quite heavy let me see the I will manage
to
leave the top and that's too heavy we
also have a rule here that ideally you
leave everything where you found it but
I will try and bring this particular
smaller branch or cheek here to show you
how exactly the fig trees look like very
popular is baboons very popular with our
particular birds like does pigeons and
Archie want me to come here this is how
they look like at the moment they are
not ripe but I've seen they make very
good food also for certain birds like
tacos this is what they tend to feed on
see that so when the ripe will change
the color and they'll either go to
orange or that kind of beautiful color
now I want to put back to put it back
where it was because you remember
earlier I said we always try to leave
things where they are that's how nature
should be and the only thing we should
leave behind here our footprints every
time me and Isaac we are talking of how
tall the grass is Ian Amara and
sometimes you even can't see us because
of the height of the grass and where
it's so difficult to see the Lions I
guess I'm about 5 5 feet something at
least definitely 6 artists a camera
operator who is showing you my face and
what I'm doing out here so I want to
show you this is the red autographs okay
sometimes we also call de cemento 305
feet and a few inches I said and I want
to show you how high this gracias so
imagine looking for lion would you be
there it makes life very difficult for
us but the Rays are going to continue so
all this grass is going to continue so I
don't have my green shoe cause yet
because when the gets colder I'll always
put it on but if I sit here
with my green suka I'll just disappear
you'll not see me anymore so that should
be much later tonight well back to
business I need to jump her back in the
car because as I had promised you before
I need to look for the sausages Thank
You Archie for your good job you made me
have a little bit of a stretch maybe at
one point we are going to have a little
change so I have to get myself an hook
to the other radio which is a Hawaiian
normally I belong Thank You Archie I
tell you if you stand out on that wind
that wind might blow you out okay very
good excellent now it's time to look for
my favorite cuts and I have done enough
exercise already
very goods after Holly having hogs the
fig tree let's go back to the Duke of
Jummah with estimable
Thank You Gigi indeed it is very
powerful to hug a tree
quiet enjoy hugging trees on a daily
basis but indeed we are still with the
Duke and isn't that incredible how tall
that red-out grass can get in the Mara
there I mean at the height of David is
not a small man so you can imagine how
everything would disappear up here if we
had the same sort of growth that's all
to do with the rain and the soil huge
the new children soil providing a hugely
nutrient-rich vegetation but it's not
always ideal when you're searching for
lions in the long grass most certainly
wouldn't be the most fun area to walk in
with the grass that long well Luke is
slowly slowly making his way towards
chillip an he knows there's always a
couple of animals hanging around over
here and he's been taking his time
showing us the patience that is the Duke
of Jummah and he's stopping right in
front of us here is right above my head
hello he's looking at chellah pan he's
looking for because there's always a
couple of Impala hanging around over
here generally just in the open area
just behind us mmm you probably could
make him wear a hat Emma I mean said was
saying earlier because we were sitting
next to him and simply saying that's the
highlights of my job we were sitting
there and I said was eating some nuts
and ting gana was right next to the car
in the shade and said zip said this is
the best part of my job getting to
suture with a leopard while having a
snack and he also said after that I wish
there were we could go up and just
cuddle them because they just look so
cuddly don't they but I'll tell you
folks leopard fur is a lot more coarse
than you think it is it's a lot tougher
it's not as and the belly may be nice
and soft but it's very very very very
coarse like not a shaggy dog like a very
hard for type of dog I'm trying to think
what kind of dog I'm sorry boy you're
right there
he says stops in the shade and I also
warn you that the smell that she'll
generate on your hands after snuggling
with a leopard like this is going to be
quite something to behold
well it seems like Sydney has either
gone somewhere else or he's moved to the
Jimmy Dean and he's got a very special
surprise I am so very lucky this
afternoon by the gym again as yesterday
I was here looking for them and there
was nothing for today oh look the
smallest one is coming now I haven't
seen this smallest one for a long time
look at that this is beautiful
oh the other one is pulling there's more
one from the ear so they are very much
inquisitive the mother is just looking
everywhere so I'm sure this is the
mother for these adults one's pretty so
the smallest one I can see there now
she's growing high up looking from the
high elevation
so the small one is very much interested
to play
so these islands they keep moving these
little ones away because of the
following reasons one they don't want
other predators in the area to detect
the scent of their little ones too when
these high infestations
of parasites such as fleas they've got
to move their little ones so there is
quite a lot of competition going on
amongst these predators as predators
such as wild dogs when we come to these
areas when they're babies
they will eat their little ones same
applies to the hyenas when they come
across the other den sites for other
predators they also eat their little
ones so that helps them in order to
minimize the competition in these areas
so in order to see the kill in order to
see the kill we've got to sometimes
depend on this kind of animals because
they have good sense of smell and they
can smell blood from a long distance so
I am most also very much happy that the
iana SAR back at Juma as it was
difficult a few weeks ago to see them
they were gone to the other side you can
see now that the mother is now working
around us trying to check what's
happening but I can see they are not
having any stress about our presence the
little ones also interested to follow
their mother in order to show us the
erode the little one other one is down
already you can see wanting to follow
the mother at the moment
so this little ones are growing very
fast look they are very much interested
in pay so the smallest one which is
still very dark or disappear
as in Blanc is growing I have seen that
first time I'm seeing them for quite a
long time I can see that they're growing
very quickly now I can see that little
one is going to follow the mother is
somewhere resting under the tree day so
the Sun is bit hot at the moment so
that's why now they're moving much more
to the other side so I'm gonna have to
change the position so that I can give
you the better sighting oh this one is
coming back again it doesn't want me to
move so this termite mound which is used
as a den side it has got the two holes
at the back there's another entrance so
they've got two entrances at the moment
so sometimes when these holes are too
open big predators such as leopard can
go in not long time ago we have
witnessed it when Tristan was lucky with
Tenggara
going deep and completely disappeared in
one of the German mounds so that is a
sign that when the Predators are in the
area can easily go down and get hold of
these little ones
and this is so cute look at that look at
this beautiful spot it's unbelievable
that when these little ones are still
young the color is completely different
just like what we saw earlier when the
little one came out so if you can
compare plunk and the a small one you
will see that they don't look the same
Nina
they look very funny especially when
looking at the body design having long
legs and short hind legs there makes it
much more interesting they just want to
sniff every time look at that you can
see that little one is trying to pick up
the sand from the the wind because there
is too much wind at the moment maybe the
wind is bringing them updates
very much inquisitive the ears are
moving all the time
the question about the termites
collapsing is very much gray I have seen
the big animals such as the elephants
you must check these termites has got
entrances entrances are not done mostly
by designers these entrances are done by
the animals such as the artifacts and
the hyenas they just come and use them
and modify them in order to get better
so that they can easily go inside but
the elephants they can weigh up to five
thousand kilograms elephants can be able
to climb up here and feed from the trees
while standing on top of the termite
mound it's very rare for a termite mound
to get dissolved also when is raining
too much they don't easily get dissolved
so the materials which is used in order
to build the termites the termite mounds
by the termites is interesting they
build this kind of big houses from their
saliva and their droppings so they've
got kind of a sticky glue which helps
them in order to stick this kind of soil
and it becomes very much hard if you go
and knock there you are going to feel
that this is very much hard it's like a
rock and it's very rough on the outside
and smooth by the inside
so hyenas a part of those animals all
got to be a thankful when it comes to
the utilization of the holes dug by the
artifact so while I'm still checking
what is going to happen around here
let's go to David by the Maasai Mara who
is lucky with the Lions hyena Cubs are
pretty good to watch in an afternoon and
we go to Cubs here but be sure before we
show you the scubs we got a very fast
team lioness here who is drinking now
this one member is a member of the
sausage tree pride and I feel full of
joy to have spotted them finally
I've been looking for them for the last
couple of three hours not sure who this
is and my guess is this is the very
famous King tell King tell is the oldest
female in this particular pride and the
other day or is it yesterday morning she
introduced us to her three cubs and how
exiting is that well for those of you
have never joined us before I got a very
special for the Lions here and I'm
saying especially because it's my
favorite pride in the matter got loads
of tries of lions fairly many over ten
points but this particular one I follow
them with the passion because of the
economics I want to show you
King tail as she is walking down towards
her two cubs I'm sure those Cubs could
be hiding for her to do what you call
hide and seek very good job Archie is
the camera operator with me this
afternoon but if you look carefully in
the grass there where Kings tail is
fitting at 12 o'clock the two smaller
Cubs hiding the grass nor small our
guest about six months old
and kink tail is followed by another
female behind I'm yet to identify who
she is just watch carefully and see what
is caps will do to the ante
yep nice play a little stretch there
excellent
stretching on four-by-four child or the
universe you would like to see all the
caps together you stay tuned up child on
the universe but seeing Kings held child
over unifies think it's pretty special
and look at those cows playing with your
mother there how come so close to a cow
so child of the universe could have
doing these Lions are on the move I do
not know where they're going but chances
are they are going to where the other
smaller Cubs are and if they end up the
action of the universe I'll be following
them there so stay tuned and you'll see
what happens so what we want to do is to
turn around and I'll be more than happy
to do that so that M we can cover a
bigger audience we just put my head down
because Archer doesn't like seeing my
head he likes seeing Lions which are
just in front of the car and not very
fiber water 3 meters of 4 meters from
the car
hello hello and jumbo jumbo and a very
warm welcome to Kenya we are in a game
reserve that is called the Mara triangle
with some very exciting playful lion
cubs oops look at that they have always
said a good picture is worth a thousand
words but I think this particular
caption graphics playing is worth our
guest a million words very windy where
we are but these Cubs are not bothered
by the blowing air up or down here in
the grass
Lynne you asking how the Cheney Cubs
doing now this particular ones here are
about six months old Lynn and they
belong to one of the females here we
haven't seen the Cheney Cubs in the
whole of today yesterday assume lean we
never saw them but yesterday morning we
saw them and I'm sure you're watching
when he's on a small little band of joy
trying to walk and she came very close
to the car and you saw her going yeah no
and she was calling so what are you
doing we'll be following this big Cubs
fear because they're following their
mother and if they're going to take as
Oya and thinking they will go yeah we'll
be able to see their smaller Cubs and
especially that very small one
now Lynn let me just go very close to
not very close rather I feel closer to
these Lions and I'll show you the lead
female and give you an idea the
direction she is going into where I got
a feeling there could be the den of kink
tails caps and the other one female now
look carefully if when you look ahead of
me see that one I understand my guess is
that is my team it is one of the
realities in this particular pride I
haven't seen her closely ever see how
could I'll be able to identify her of
the five females in this pride she got
the darkest or very brown eyes and she
got a small split on her right nose
Curren you're saying yes cabs can turn
out to be ferocious ferocious rather as
they grow and this is an indication of
what will happen to these cabs as they
grow older now we have confirmed 100%
these two cabs here
Mills of course after about a month a
month and a half if you look at them
carefully and closely with below their
tails you can tell what sex they are and
this two boys maybe that's a 9th month
that we are going to see small signs of
men coming out of the necks so these are
the oldest cub of the associate tree
pride about six months old there's
another cab almost the same age which is
about five months old and her mother is
called Limpy she isn't here and of
course that other cab that belongs to
Limpy they're not here both of them now
kink tail is one female also in this
particular pride that we saw earlier she
got a knot on her tail that's why we
call her king tail and we think she got
three cubs this one more a female here
that had put my mind on my brain in a
spin the other day because we have never
seen her meeting with anybody we have
never seen her pregnant but one of the
very small tiny cub that we think Robin
even nine or ten days old we saw her
yesterday so we are just wait and see
most likely nothing now from the
position there are in there definitely
scanning you can see they're just
looking around and scanning I'm talking
of them looking for some dinner
they mean spot some animals at the
moment the main sport some pre now and
then later on we'll take advantage of
the darkness now look at that particular
one she is on top of atomic mound and
that gives her a vantage point of like
360 degrees to look around and see where
Buffalo's for example could be
isn't that special what are you thinking
looking - looking at each other and oh
that's right we need to have proper
identity and the good news angel we can
identify King tail 150% we can identify
Mitty 150% and we need to look at them
more carefully and you will know who is
who well ladies and gentlemen I'm very
happy that you've been able to watch
this with us and I hope you're all
excited just like me haven't you
well my name my name is David and on
camera with me was Archie please stay on
the lookout you might be sending you
more notifications much later on we're
gonna give you one more quick look of
these particular beautiful ions and for
myself and Archie many thanks and
goodbye
well welcome back our regular viewers
and I'm sure we are all enjoying this
particular sighting here
those two cabs are sitting very close to
some water there we have a little stream
that flows down there but they don't
seem very thirsty not sure they haven't
eaten meat but what would happen is when
they eat meat you'll always see them
coming to have a drink very interesting
look at the color of that water it looks
very dark very mucky but I'm most here
in the wilderness
we'll always drink that water as it is
and they never get issues not sure
what'll happen to me or gee if you go
drink the same water but it's a
wonderful the kind of immune system of
how or how their bodies work that they
can comfortably drink water like this
and nothing actually would happen well
happy man today having seen my favorite
pride of lions and a thing a treat got a
lion should won't talk about
I certainly am enjoying my cats in fact
I wish they were as playful as David had
right there I was just saying to BK
these Cubs are hogging all the cat
action but I suppose they're just way
too cute you just can't stop looking at
them myself even they are just the most
stunning hair little creatures ever and
imagine that they turn into these sort
of beasts in five to seven years
stunning so these guys were born in 2013
so there'll be six this year I don't
know if we know the exact month but
definitely 2013 and they'll be their
biggest and their main will be the
they're sort of darkest and biggest when
they're about 7 so maybe there's even
more to go more main and more size to
see I can't wait to watch them actually
fiona says their stomachs must be
hardened now I would think so although
it does look like they haven't really
yeah it looks like they haven't eaten I
really hope that they get a kill you
know with the way that they were sort of
mentioning about I thought that they
were could the Lions injury have been
from a snake bite what had thought I
actually didn't even think about that
well apart from the injury on the actual
head that I suppose could be a Fang but
then there would be two puncture wounds
and it looks like a massive puncture
wound but then again it could have
started small and then gotten big I
don't know he does have a few swelling
on some joints as well I suppose if if
he had some sort of snake bite that
could be the case too but I don't know
it seems like it kind of goes through
the skull just a bit or into the skull
just a bit some of you guys are
wondering if a lion would die from a
snake bite I suppose in the same way as
a human may die from a snake bite it
doesn't happen often most of the time
when a when a snake bites you you can
experience horrible repercussions and
that sort of thing but death is not
usually on the cards unless it's
something very very venomous maybe like
a black mamba or a Boomslang or a vine
snake even a vine snake I don't think it
can actually kill you but it will the
venom there is no anti-venom for it so
you'll just have to kind of suffer
through and I'm pretty sure that most
other mammals will also feel the same
sort of effects
but the benefit that us humans have is
having access to medical care and of
course anti-venom if and when we need it
something that these animals don't have
and the other thing is we have people
who bring us food take us to hospital
take care of us bring us anything we
need and if you're out in the wild and
you're in that situation most of the
time the best you're gonna get is
exactly what we're seeing here you're
gonna get some guidance from your your
kind of group members in this case his
coalition and then apart from that
there's not much else he can do he can
take down a kill but I don't know if
he'd drag it to the brother he did lead
him to some water early on the waters
just actually ahead of us in this little
little patch right so he let his brother
to some water but like I said I think
that's the best that can be done it's
not like he can get get his brother to
kind of bandage up or something like
that so I hope he does get better and I
really hope it's not a snake bite at all
I really don't well I'm gonna stay here
I'm enjoying my time with the cats and
the breeze and the grass and the
meantime let's go to Steve mmm it has
suddenly gotten a bit warmer the wind is
not as powerful as it was and cats are
lying down well we followed him for some
time he's now here in the shade perfect
ambush position from one watching hole
to another and he's hoping something is
going to come down and drink but we are
going to stay right yet so we don't miss
any of the action he doesn't look like
he's gonna be giving any action for any
time anytime soon but needless to say
and we are with him and we will remain
so
the Duke of jummah don't forget folks we
are live and we have got many questions
and answers for you well you've got the
questions we got the answers please feel
free to send them through on hashtag
Safari live or drop them on the YouTube
chat stream let us know what you'd like
to talk about with regards to Tigana
here of course Emma if you could just
let Trish Allah know that someone's
trying to get her on the game Drive
radio please that would be awesome
it's really nice after the rain nice
sunshine coming out hello riot Your
Honor not survival advantage spotted fur
has four leopards well essentially it
makes them extremely camouflaged and
well when you're a young cub trying to
avoid detection from large predators
that might see to do you harm well you
can hide away but also a leopard uses
its spots for camouflage to sneak up as
close as possible if the leopard was
only white it's a very good chance that
it would not be able to sneak up or be
stealthy at all it would just stand out
very clearly but it's really incredible
how well camouflaged a leopard really is
bearing in mind the herbivores and the
prey animals out yeah they they see with
a black and white division so they
actually don't be they're not able to
pick out much of the sort of definition
of a cat and what the spots do they
break up the outline and what black and
white division animals are need to do is
they need to basically be able to see an
outline it's all about outline and they
get a shape sort of an image and so I
want a leopard sticks its head over a
termite mound it flattens its ears so
that it blends in with the term outbound
but animals are looking for a specific
shape and it's the same with predators
they're looking for a shape that agree
they see definition and Yala and could
ruin alike they are able to break up
this their 3d shape with the stripes and
the fur that they have on their body and
I was actually I witnessed a little bit
of research taking place in a reserve
some American University I forget the
name we're trying to test the theory
with lions that were there and they were
dragging these cuts out cardboard sort
of things of Impala behind the car and
the Lions were reacting to it they were
chasing these cardboard cutouts because
of the shape so it's quite incredible
and it's all about search image and
that's why leopards and lions don't
really pay attention to us in a car they
get used to the fact that we are part of
the car but if I stood up and got out
the car they'll see that shape that is
me and well not necessarily me but that
is associated with humans and humans too
leopards and lions and most other
animals is regarded as danger as we
evolved with him on the African plains
and we were very very adept hunters and
gatherers and we used to fight for our
place in at the system but right now
Kangana is not doing anything ok well it
seems like David is with the cats that
are playing around let's go back up to
MIT with a world of cuteness it's very
typical forecast to be flat sometimes as
Kangana is doing now but the very
opposite of this different species of
casts I got here and you can see how
playful they are now a third cup that
had not seen before just came and joined
not knowing there's another lioness
elsewhere and I guess that one other
lioness must harden Limpy because Limpy
got one camper that's about five months
old
so I got four females here and three
cubs
I've stopped here just watch them where
they going but I got a feeling the
direction they're going into this little
forest ahead of them and that's her most
likely then of one of the female is not
here which I think have the youngest and
the smallest any camp is and she could
be learning how one cub and king stirs a
3-car Kings tail is another female here
but we call her by the name because you
are not on her tail for those of you who
could be joining us now this has two of
those counts and again if you look
carefully yeah [ __ ] raised from the
ground it's modular termite mound and
the whole idea is just come that's what
they do when it's not very hot on the
out of the shade and once they identify
the prey then they will make strategies
and plans on how to hunt I only guess
they could be going for
Buffalo and not anything else look at
the background and see the cloud hanging
there beautiful beautiful and those are
the plains of the Merritt triangle will
always have tree lines along the loggers
and yes in the final control sisters
quite stunning and that's one of the
Vantage of seeing where we are Fiona
you'd like to know why they're called
the Big Five there have been a few
theories of how that phrase was coined
Fiona and I would say number one way
back we had hunters when hunting was
very big in Africa we had the hunters
coming all over the world I mean from
all over the world from the US I mean
from North America Europe and they'd
come and hunt animals and one of the
theories or you know how they love
without faces they are the animals that
still hunt for trophies
so buffalos for example they would hunt
them for the huge rock two horns and
they used to do the bigger of the white
of the horn the bigger of the value of
the trophy was today that might have
changed a little bit because what they
do they look at how wide the base of the
hornies on what they call volumetrics
and that's more in the mayor's didn't
used to hunt femurs but if the thymus
had huge horns that could come out that
would be one reason of course Lions they
would definitely be hunting the male the
male says you go back to those times
there are Fiona
because of the main layer parts the
beautiful skins with the rosette rhinos
there was always that myth you know I
rhinos had some affair Jurassic you know
properties on the horns and what have I
forgotten of the big five and what else
of course the elephant's Fiona because
of the ivory and ivory makes wonderful
calvings
ivory makes carvings that they that
leave for thousands of thousands of
years before the way out that's one of
the reasons why they call in the big
five and the number two Fiona this to me
some of the most dangerous animals that
we got in Africa so those two results
that's how they ended up calling them
the big
five it's one lioness that sustained
back as the others are still walking
away they're walking stopping looking
and the cabs are you sure obeying
playful went cool stuff like this and
the one that's leading the pride is just
moving in that direction to us those
trees there and as I said earlier my
guess is this could be meaty and meaty
have pretty small calves about six weeks
old and I this time to go do a bit of
cycling for the Cubs but of course like
any other mother you do not want to be
staying so long away from your little
Cubs
well this one's here they have joined
the few of them together and it's time
to strengthen their muscles and hoping
one day they'll do count very good
hunters well now can manage to fog them
closely and find out where they want to
go so that I do not lose the sight and
Sydney might have moved from the
Highness I am now hearing much more
towards the central part of the reserve
just to go and try to see if I cannot be
lucky with calamba I have been here
yesterday it was difficult
there was no luck on Columba maybe this
afternoon is going to be my lucky day
that's just quite a lot of elephant sex
everywhere
maybe these elephants are gonna push
Colombo out for me so I left they are in
a den because the inés just got
disappeared they all went in there and
relax so there was no exciting anymore
so that is why I had to leave the den I
will maybe go back again afterwards
so with the rain drizzling every night
is difficult to see the fresh tracks on
these cats
so the potholes they are getting very
deep
the big five animals as a david ignited
the topic earlier on those animals that
category is a category of the animals
which were giving the hunters a big
problem during the olden days during the
olden days when people were still
depending on hunting for survival they
were having serious problems when it
comes to the category of the big five in
other words is animals that always
retaliate when coming across the human
beings so I'm very sure what modified
the behavior on those animals to be
aggressive towards us as humans is they
have realized human was becoming their
biggest enemy and that is normal if you
can check until today in the areas where
there is some both legal and illegal
hunting the behavior of animals get
modified and every time they pick a
human scent they become wary and always
got prepared for a fight
so this area where I'm passing now from
yesterday I'm picking up very strong
smell left behind by the hippopotamus so
II Papa Chavez are some of those animals
which can be able to travel long
distances so it means this is the
grazing area so there's even all the
tracks of this repose in this area
so now let's quickly go back to one of
these animals Oh does retaliate when
coming across people if you are to close
the layer part well you're back indeed
to the sleeper and the ting Ghana who is
an expert sleeper and while we've spent
many an hour watching him sleep he's not
as animated as husana is when husana
sleeps when husana sleeps he is always
moving a leg or there's a face moving
something going on but in Ghana is
dreaming sweet sweet dreams that seem to
be very pleasant what do you think folks
that he's dreaming if you were the Duke
of Jummah what do you think it would be
going on in your mind
hashtag safari love if you have any
thoughts and comments about what you
think it's in Ghana might be dreaming as
he slumbers there in the lovely shade
well wonderful I can hear an orange
bracelet Bush shark in the background
good time to do some birding it's me
making it rattling sistah killer calling
some Aramark babblers with their
characteristic loud
babbling cackle that they do number of
starlings have been flying through and I
can also hear a gray headed sparrow that
hi son I'm not very good at the sparrows
call hmm he could be dreaming about
birds or maybe he's dreaming about one
of those kuru that he didn't catch you
know one of those dreams you have when
you're trying to grab something or catch
something assistant you could just never
get it it's always just out of grasp
that must happen to leopards because
they miss a lot
you know everybody looks at leopards and
thinks about how successful they are but
very often they must only with about 20%
a success rate jerilyn the European
Parliament Arak and there's definitely a
parlor on the brain they're fleeing
parlor maybe he's thinking about how
nice those two Steinbach would have been
earlier that he must have you seen him
with a steam box Abe I haven't seen him
with his team buck I've seen Tandy with
a few and Dingaan has been with many a
day care whether he courts that are not
just debatable he's stolen him from his
ex-wife I do wonder they if the mating
that went on between Tandy and tengan a
few weeks ago is going to lead is going
to lead to any sort of Cubs from Tandy
we haven't seen her in at least a week
and a half
Arizona he's dreaming of younger Daiso
7-hour commenting when we saw him before
in the shade he he was definitely
looking a little bit more disheveled
around the head and neck around the ears
you Coralie notice it now but he was
really really close to us at the time
and we got right up on him on him then
he's just looking really really sort of
Haggard it's looking in fine condition
but the fur around is around his face is
just starting to really start losing his
sort of beauty and lots of ticks almost
a little bit of mange developing around
the head but it's not as obvious now
that he's lying down but we had a really
good view of him before before we
started napping
so 13 years old somewhere around there
there's a very good age from a leopard I
mean in fula was looking also quite to
the scraggly last year I only saw him
once last year he was looking quite
quite skinny and thin he'd lost a lot of
fur
lost a lot of condition never seen him
in his prime days but he was a
magnificent leopard so I was told
see some images and that is the way with
all these big cats is they hold on so as
long as they can and unfortunately once
retirement sets in they do diminish
quite quickly but everybody out there
seems to think and agree that he's got
at least another year in Him which is
very very possible the way he's going I
mean he's he's gone from having a
shrunken territory last year to pushing
even further this year and last year
into Torchwood and before sook and other
areas we don't even know but anyway it
seems as if the Avoca boys have decided
to get a little bit of a spring in their
step let's go and see if they're gonna
get up to anything interesting yes my
cat has started to move just a bit but
not gotten off the ground unfortunately
but the head has picked up nose a bit of
scratching going on and he rolled onto
his backer then his brother rolled onto
his back so there's little contagious
behavior going on here so I wonder if
brother will start scratching soon nope
he's just knocked out now actually got
quite excited when he rolled over
because it looked like he had this huge
barely knows whoa oh you've got a great
meal but it is in fact not his baby have
a closer look and you can see that it's
actually his rib cage and you can see
that well-defined sort of V right there
where you can see the breath in and a
breath out yeah so he doesn't look well
fed he just looks like he's got great
big pair ups
he does look awfully comfortable too
although for someone who's unfed maybe
his brother right there I might be able
to hunt something and then they could
share it yes these boys probably are
also dreaming of food liked in Ghana
well one is definitely dreaming of food
the other one is actually trying to plan
how to get it he's being slightly more
productive interestingly I read about
dreaming in mammals and whether they
actually have the ability to dream and
it was found that almost all mammals go
through a stage of REM sleep even if
it's just a couple minutes so the
potential to dream is there and what
their dreams contain who knows most
likely food I would say the basic
functions food chasing running walking
smelling something no I think that sort
of thing the other night I dreamt of
donuts just to put that in perspective
yes I dream of donuts you dream of kudu
actually was a good dream until I
entered this it was sort of like a
24-hour you know convenience store kind
of thing and then there was a big sign
that said no donut Tuesdays now why on
earth would you put on a sign that said
no donut Tuesdays usually you'd be
advertising the donuts and it was very
upset and then the lady said no I'll
make you a donut and then she brought
the donut to me and then it fell on the
ground it's true I don't know what my
subconscious is doing to me so if that's
the type of dreams I am having can you
imagine what these guys must be having
they almost see a big sign that says
kudou here and then they get there in
this it's empty
Oh imagine if it's dead that no impala
Monday how upset would you be I'm sure
you would be really upset get that spot
get that spot
now this guy here it was always hard
kind of to tell exactly which one is
which when you have them singly but when
you have them together it's much easier
so I now seeing the both of them I can
positively identify that that guy there
is definitely the mohawked male or
snarly when he opens his mouth you can
see that he's bottom incisors are all
sort of crooked and that is a defining
characteristic of him and that only
leaves the blonde male and the dark mane
male and he's the injured one is
definitely not a dark mane male so I
would say this is blondie and Mohawk
slash snarling so dark mane male is
still AWOL at this point david is
following the sausages I bet these guys
would dream of sausages in the meantime
let's go to him
very good Trish to identify their vocals
because for me there's something that
figures there that you cannot see and
that's where the King to lameness just
entered what I would want to tell you
for a fact I'll guess that is I knew
then because she was previously is about
a mile from yeah oh yeah just about mile
or so from where she is now I've been
following her for the last ten minutes
but she just came and she entered and
Sam here here aren't you gonna show you
that particular press right now and she
has not moved and you can tell or you
can see that's her den because of how
thick it is there's a bit of a depth or
a ditch and that's a very ideal place to
hide cups so nothing is our guest second
then after she moved her cubs from the
first place why she gave birth to them
and once a while Lena says will always
move the Cubs once in a while to avoid
detection from Cubs
I mean to avoid detection from predators
for example what Isaac got
well welcome back I'm here with the
North clan the North clan is a clan of
highness that has been studied here for
what a good number of years we have the
main mature call waffles
she is not present but she is very well
presented by plenty and plenty of cups
of different ages this one here I don't
know his new he's a new member of a
Northland only about three and a half
four months so I don't know his name but
the next coming months we'll be able to
tell you what they have named him yes
you can tell they are all well rested
remember to join me in conversation I
will be here for the rest of the time so
please join me in the conversation
I'm putting myeloma voice low so that I
don't disturb them they're rather a
Chinese little white guys you can chat
to me on hashtag Safari life or you can
watch me on YouTube livestream
I'm RT what we know Northland then and
this is our then that has got plus minus
over 60 members yes there are 60 members
over 60 members in this clan that female
they're a fish is the babysitter
she has been left to take care of the
youngsters
to me if you don't ask me I will tell
you that over here you can tell yes
waffles is still very much the leader
nothing has changed I did my study well
last night and yes she still the main
leader her daughter passed one of the
daughters passed away and the soup the
same fat daughter has given birth and
they asked I think some of the Cubs here
belong to her and I think she will be
the one to take over from waffles once
she's you know ready to hand over the
leadership I think it wouldn't come easy
but at all the edge you will be able to
you know have know otherwise but to hand
over call six you were wondering about
the Northland here they are
I'm glad he were inefficient enough
because we are also wondering exactly
what had happened but due to rains they
had they had moved their dance twice so
it was rather difficult to follow them
we don't have the tracking device to
follow waffles who's got the color the
who's got the color and we don't have
the tracking device to fall off so for
us we have to follow her manually and
follow them manually so eventually we
found this there not even a week ago so
we're very very grateful and happy the
vehicle you just saw it belongs to the
hyena research project they have the
permission to be much much closer than a
normal distance so don't you worry they
term people know what they are doing and
actually I think they're gonna come up
with a lot of new study about this
beautiful predator hyenas are perceived
to be you know I've always said this you
know dirty scouring mosque scroungy mean
but it is actually a very I like a my
very you know successful predator he
does make most of its kills
and much more active than other
predators you know they will always be
moving they'll always be doing something
and like you know leopard or lion if you
find them eating after eating you know
they'll just lay rest these guys are
always very active there's a little guy
who's way back there and I think he's
chewing on a cow on an old you know hide
maybe from a hippo from Buffalo I can
imagine how hard it is it's like
shooting an old boat you need to have
lots of saliva and very sharp teeth so
yes actually it's unlike a chew toy yes
so actually I think that's what he is
doing they are the only few predators
that will be able to eat those kind of
hard stuff you know skins bones and that
one there is taking care of an old skin
this den here I was here last night and
there were two that were really oh there
we go oh she was just fighting there
look at her
nice Oh a wonderful to see her yeah
she's actually getting quite old you can
tell Wow yes yes yes this is just
awesomeness well you know she's a good
leader as you can tell she's given other
other females confidence to breed and so
that's why she's got lots and lots of
daughters and all the daughters have
given birth so this is a huge huge
family yeah yes I'm so happy you know
that everybody is happy to see waffles
yes they know you were quite worried but
don't you worry anymore we have her and
she's well as you can see and she's
still in charge
I think she is babysitting today because
yesterday I came as she wasn't here so
it's really really great
to see her and looks like everybody is
very very healthy over here and today
after there's not much tension that last
night last night I came here if in case
you didn't join me and there was a bit
of tension there was some cups that
couldn't come out of they then because
every time they prefer heads out there's
a babysitter who you know walk towards
the dinner and they would run quickly
towards the hole so I don't know exactly
what what was going on but today
grandmother is around so all is well you
can tell you know there's a little one
if you zoom in to the right a little bit
there Gendry you'll see there's a little
ones popping yeah yeah yeah see that
there is another little one cute yeah I
think peacefully still not confident
enough to come out so you see it's gone
back
yes in a while I sit here with this nice
spotted hyenas let me let me take you to
some more spotted animals down in do one
we haven't seen in ages easy to identify
those and she Isaac I know he was having
a chat last night about he's not sure if
you daddy her but it's very easy when
you see that collar and very very easy
indeed I like it when he says that while
all the hyenas are well behaved while
grandmas watching
does it remind you all a little bit of
your upbringing I mean um
did you behave with Grandma were you
were you a bit more naughty with grandma
my grandma was it was pretty strict many
grandparents that generally because
there might have been a strict mom or
dad are generally quite relaxed with
their kids aren't that with their
grandkids who spoiled them a little bit
more seeing is that they don't have to
be the doting parent got an elephant
over there that's what he was looking at
said the herd of elephants just crossing
the road in front of us there we go he
had his head up it's having a look at
something something moved and well he
realized there's an elephant and well
that's well beyond his reach of
capabilities
well it's floppy yeah hello floppy yeah
there's also grandma right there I would
say a nice herd of them coming out into
the open yes they are that is the way it
works you just have to spend enough time
in one place and you know all the
animals will come out it's all about
patience I once spent three whole days
at a watering hole and a little bit of a
chalet there a little a very rudimentary
bungalow and we saw probably about 20
different runners
three different lions two packs of wild
dog while they were the same pack of
wild dogs with jackal that hyena
elephant all came out to the water all
you do is you just sit and wait and
eventually
the resource of the watering hole will
attract the animals down if you have the
patients highly recommend doing that
just with a few friends and that's quiet
weekend away very very cool than the
African wilderness with fires of course
and the night sky as if you haven't been
arts Africa that is one of the
highlights of being art in here is the
evening sounds and the beautiful stars
that we have out and is a very non
populated areas lacking pollution hello
little you want to know how the SPC show
is stopping while it's a 13-part series
and tonight is episode 13 so once the
seasons done then obviously successes
and failures will be addressed and then
but we're pitching or I think we are
scheduled to do a second one starting on
the 7th of April busy negotiating the
finer points that I do believe but a
season is a season and it has to come to
an end at some point and we did seven
thirteen episodes even though there was
a bit of a gap in the middle for some
cricket those of you who don't
understand cricket you wouldn't really
know but it's all about finishing a
season and then off it starts again just
like the binge series that was a series
as well with a number of episodes the
last one who did as well the gauntlet
series also economy member how many we
did but there's a finite number that are
allocated to a series or season and then
you do another one which is very very
cool I'm very excited for our final
episode and that's why we ever spent so
much time with it in Ghana today because
what we don't want to lose him the Juke
has to have the final word you see honor
the end of the essay BC three first
season for the safari live and hopefully
the Avoca males will stay as well for
the show they're going a little bit east
hopefully they don't go too far north
well it's in Tricia's hands to keep up
with him
yes they were sticking around but right
now I have decided to move off idea
PK can you see them there we go
they've just had the most wonderful
thing they have the winds been blowing
in their face and their manes are sort
of just been blowing it looks like a
like a magazine shoot to be very honest
and they just kind of had their noses up
remember if the wind is blowing into
them then they can smell everything else
that's been collected up by the wind so
maybe they're out in the hunt who knows
here they come past us it was just the
most stunning scene
absolutely stunning scene of course
Niki would like to know if the wind
helps to keep flies away I haven't ever
thought about it for lions but I do know
that I mean when we have mosquitoes in
the camp one thing I really do do is put
the fan on and it really does help with
the with the mosquitoes and suppose any
flying flying insect to be honest and
I'm sure the wind kind of helps them but
I can't imagine if something stuck in
their Mane that it does too much I think
the main purpose for them is to be able
to smell everything that's coming up
with that wind
we really are magnificent but can you
see the ridges of his spine along there
now we do have other people in the
sighting of course so that's the other
vehicle that you are seeing it's a bit
harder to maneuver around but
nonetheless everyone wants to get a good
sighting of these two especially since
we haven't seen them together for a
while well at least these guys haven't
as well so
just make sure my game drive radio is up
oh you can still see them in front thing
now can you see the way that brother
it's kind of oh I can hear something
funny in my yeah Emma you can see the
way that the brothers are kind of
following each other and they have this
really strong bond going on and this is
something so precious to see I think
oh it is very very windy now I'm going
to try and get around here and see if we
can get a bit of a better view luckily
it's not too thick around yeah
they actually are some open spaces to
get in now where you - there they are
again they're kind of catching the wind
hazard they kind of just catching the
wind and it looks absolutely stunning
now here's one right here beautiful
speaking I don't know if you can
actually see them there with all the Sun
in the wind there we go now I can't
having a few comms issues but I heard
the word David David
so I let's go to David well I moved out
and followed one lioness who I believe
was meaty and she took me about 300
meters from where I am and I guess
that's where meeting got her four cups
now this is the spot I was earlier if we
can remember that broken tree where King
tell went in King tell is one of the
females in this particular parade well
after having a meaty gone in a ditch
that I cannot see anything or even hotel
either let me come back to these two
other girls well one of them is Limpy
because of course our cab is here and
the other feeling that you don't have a
name
who got two caps but now this one's
luckily they have stayed out here that
because I've just had a small to call
from one of the Cubs and I think that's
one of the
kinkiest caps and she did our distress
that's why you saw that particular alien
lioness reacts like that but I think all
should be fine so she's going to watch
that direction well we could not cking
tell and of course the other female
there who I guess to be limping as all
the three cubs and just chroming which
is very typical of the Lions
I'm so happy at least these two mothers
and these three cabs have remained
outside the den because if they would
have joined kingster that to be a bit
other to be tougher for me to be able to
see them in that little hidden I would
say the German muffled closer so what we
want to do just a little bit closer and
see if Kingston might come out
I think by the time she came here she
must have spent enough time
maybe supplying those cups she could be
coming out any time so let me just give
a different angle
okay now the wind is still blowing
nothing has changed but it's not as -
Wow
our small is the same as when he was
started because I can hate hauling in my
ears and unlike the Buffaloes that we
saw earlier which looked you know to be
unsure of the wind in general lions
don't get bothered by the wind this is
very good the thing today is there for
predators and wind and I think also
Isaac is in the wind but with different
predators
well I'm still here with the Northland
and they all seem to be attracted by
something in the long grass there they
do what is called pasting where the
animal glands will secrete a certain
type of tasty substance and they would
apply it into the grass and that is a
sort of a way of communicating to one
another especially with clan members and
they were sniffing the long grass over
there and I thought maybe another know
another clan member came across here and
pasted because they all got very
interested and they moved there you can
tell that everybody is hanging around
granny
waffles herself in case you're joining
us for the first time this is called the
North clan
it's a clan of hyenas that has been
studied for quite some time by
University of color California in
America and they've been following them
for more than I think about ten years
and they know quite a lot the oldest
female she's called waffles and she's
got a daughter called soup
most of super daughters are named after
different kinds of soups like mushroom
like what else do we have
you know parcel like what else card soup
the the named after you know different
names so in the coming months I will be
able to show them to you and to give
them the names of who is who
but unlike what it is written in the
books where you know the mashiac is the
only one that gives above you know the
hyenas here haven't read those books and
they don't know to follow that here
there is a lot of cups so it tells me it
is not only you know waffles who gives
baths also the other you know females
give birth so it has broken the rules
and you can tell these two are maybe the
same age
yes in a while I sit here and enjoy this
lovely the cute cups limit and send you
to Trish who's got a beautiful liar
Oh wonderful lions you have made a
special appearance for us today uh in
fact to the stars to take us to the end
of the show super excited as always I'm
always super excited anteye it's just
because I love these things they're just
so pretty
absolutely beautiful and today's
relationship you I don't know how many
times I've turned around to be king gold
oh oh did you see that cuz it's just
stunning and with the green and the wind
and the way it all just blows into their
Mane actually leaves me a bit speechless
obviously with this job you can't be
speechless no no except right there was
speechless
child of the universe says this was a
great drive for a Sunday I think so too
I'm so glad team Ghana has made an
appearance we've got the second Avoca
male come in I just think it was
wonderful and we had the Cubs we had the
sausage tree pride we had their Cubs the
hyena Cubs oh it's just been beauty
absolute beauty the Sun is slowly
setting here in South Africa slowly
setting over our beautiful lions of
course we do have our s ABC show season
finale in half an hour and you can guys
can of course catch that on YouTube and
you are so welcome to we love to have
our regular viewers on board always a
pleasure
I'm glad they've decided to settle down
again again they didn't walk long they
were just he let his brother here and
you said here brother have a rest before
we're off again so they'll sit out the
sunset here and it'll set behind them
just beautifully and as the Sun sets on
our lovely lions the Sun sets of course
on our drive this afternoon thank you so
much for your questions and comments
don't forget you can join us on the
YouTube channel in half an hour for the
sabc show as well but for now bye bye
[Music]